i
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 sawyer migue fernández
comenzamos
en américa del norte la industria del
porno en línea está en auge en canadá se
están llevando a cabo muchas sesiones
fotográficas de bajo presupuesto luego
las fotos y vídeos terminan en
plataformas de transmisión que se
encuentran entre los sitios web más
visitados del mundo pero no todo el
contenido pornográfico se produce
legalmente algunos se publican sin el
consentimiento de los involucrados y
esto puede equivaler a pornografía
infantil o violación en eeuu por primera
vez 50 mujeres en california presentaron
una denuncia contra magic la empresa
matriz de los sitios de contenido
pornográfico
incluido por hub estas plataformas con
miles de millones de vistas a veces
esconden el sufrimiento de las personas
que por lo general suelen ser mujeres
porque encuentran sus vídeos publicados
sin tener consentimiento france soir y
why nuestro corresponsal en montreal
canadá llevó a cabo esta investigación
periodística junto a fanny chauvín
alumna anac y aquí la historia
[Música]
y hacer
no
sábado por la tarde en una hervía embi
de montreal perfecto si sonríe un poco
perfecto puedes ponerte así como estabas
ahí de lado luego voltea t sí muéstrame
un poco las nalgas así está perfecto
después de dos semanas de
investigaciones y de muchas negativas el
cerrado mundo del porno canadiense
finalmente le abrió las puertas a
nuestra cámara trato de tener al menos
unas 30 o 40 fotos que se puedan
utilizar ok bueno aquí vamos a pretender
que te estás desvistiendo así te vi de
24 años es una estrella local del porno
en internet conocida en la escena como
véronique tingler hola soy the navy y
beruti nclr hoy queremos saber quién es
la más linda y le vamos a pedir a jesse
jones su opinión
nos vemos en pegas
de mí y sus compañeros de hoy están
acostumbrados a las grabaciones de poco
presupuesto en que ellos mismos se
encargan de hacer la promoción por redes
sociales de cuál es tu cuenta de twitter
o tu nombre podemos etiquetar en los
pits
sí claro todo sirve para fidelizar a los
fanáticos que ascienden a decenas de
miles en el caso de este actor
canadiense radicado en los ángeles bueno
amigos hoy me puse mis gafas de geek
estoy en montreal para grabar con la
estrella cómo te llamas y vengo tingler
véronique tinkler y the navy
chicos añadiré sus cuentas sigan las por
instagram twitter por donde quiera yo
tengo mucha suerte hoy
maquillaje firma de un contrato de
trabajo y lectura del guión de la
grabación
este es el contrato donde aparece mi
edad
mi nombre y los detalles de la escena
todo está cuidadosamente preparado
escrito y aprobado antes de pasar a la
acción listo y déjame ver
una cámara de vigilancia lo graba todo
sin interrupciones
vídeo promo un concepto uno y acciones
super eso está perfecto
ahora te preguntas quién es la mejor y
así
[Música]
dependiendo del contenido del guión por
este tipo de escena actores y actrices
reciben un pago de entre 1000 y 1200
dólares canadienses
estuvo bien muy bien si fue consensuado
no tomaste drogas alcohol no eres mayor
de 18 años sí
perfecto corresponde al monto que
habíamos acordado sí
[Música]
de esta grabación saldrá un vídeo de
unos 30 minutos que se subirá a internet
y pronto estará disponible para su
visualización en línea a cambio de una
suscripción mensual para publicitarlo y
generar audiencia a algunos fragmentos
podrán ser publicados en páginas de
pornografía gratuitas también conocidas
como tips
ah
no va a aceptar
porque hoy en día las verdaderas
estrellas mundiales del porno son esas
malditas ex vídeos ex hamsters y el
famoso por javi todos estos youtube de
porno son algunas de las páginas web más
visitadas del mundo es una industria
omnipresente pero también confidencial
las pocas cifras disponibles le
atribuyen un volumen de negocios anual
entre 3 y varias decenas de miles de
millones de dólares y aunque la
pornografía ya no ocupa un tercio del
internet como se creía en los años 90
sigue estando en el corazón de las
búsquedas según google en los últimos 12
meses por jab se buscó más que joe biden
kobe 19 o netflix el problema es que
algunos de los miles de vídeos
publicados a diario en estas plataformas
tienen una procedencia criminal otros
fueron robados o son difundidos con la
intención de perjudicar nos dirigimos a
nueva york donde james aceptó contarnos
su historia
pensaba que se había terminado y esta
mañana porque va a aparecer en internet
jane no es su verdadero nombre prefirió
mantener el anonimato pero nos autorizó
a seguirla durante un encuentro con su
abogada esta mañana en el sur de central
park lo que me molestó confort es que
quitaban los vídeos pero las páginas
seguían activas muchas otras personas
afirman haber vivido la misma historia
que ya la mayoría son mujeres todas con
un mismo punto de partida un vídeo fotos
íntimas de las que perdieron el control
ya no me siento segura aquí todas acusan
a por javi gigante de sexo gratuito en
internet de haberse beneficiado de
contenidos que ellas exigían cada día
que fuesen eliminados
yo hoy día con un hombre mi ex y el me
pegaba me agredía me estrangulaba
lo detuvieron
y en agosto de 2019 me envió un link
diciendo mira por solo envío a mi hija y
mira tu madre la que es y desde ese día
los vídeos están en internet
en el vídeo de su relación sexual
publicado por su ex pareja en punjab
jane dice que también aparece su nombre
su dirección su cargo de trabajo y la
dirección de su oficina al igual que su
número de teléfono
pidió que los quitaran pero el vídeo ha
vuelto a aparecer en internet una y otra
vez desde hace tres años
había hombres que me contactaban todo el
tiempo a mí ya mis hijos porque él había
subido sus fotos a internet vi sus datos
de contactos
para mí era como una agresión sexual
virtual virtual pero constante para la
abogada laurent a bachelet el problema
no radica tanto en el funcionamiento de
internet sino en la manera en la que
estas plataformas se están aprovechando
de contenido ilegal este no es un caso
aislado no es un accidente todo este
modelo de negocio se basa en contenidos
no consensuados palabras como violación
agresión adolescentes están por todas
partes en sus páginas y el hecho de que
esos términos se propongan de manera
específica o estén disponibles
días de búsqueda demuestra que no se
puede simplemente eliminar esos
contenidos y seguir adelante
sencillamente no funciona así
con más de 170 millones de visitantes al
día en sus diferentes páginas web man
clic el propietario de pool up es uno de
los líderes mundiales del sector el
grupo también es objeto de varios
procesos judiciales acaba de firmar un
acuerdo confidencial con 50 demandantes
que afirman haber sido parte de una
operación de trata de seres humanos con
fines de explotación sexual a sus
dirigentes les gusta la discreción nunca
conceden entrevistas a los medios las
únicas fotos recientes que se conocen el
principal accionario de man kick verdad
mac son estas fueron tomadas en mayo
pasado en un barrio de londres como
líderes del sector compartimos las
preocupaciones de este comité sobre el
contenido de cal en internet
los dirigentes de manyi que radicados en
canadá dieron una declaración en febrero
pasado delante de un comité de ética
parlamentaria un suceso poco usual
más del 12 por ciento de los adultos
canadienses visitan nuestras páginas
cada día ante la multiplicación de las
acusaciones entre las cuales está haber
obtenido beneficio vídeos que contenían
explotación sexual infantil y
violaciones mind y afirma haber
reforzado sus controles de acceso y
retirado entre 9 y 10 millones de vídeos
de paul hay que reconocer que hicieron
cambios en el 2020 pero si los hubiesen
hecho antes hoy no habría tantas
víctimas y no es así no realmente si me
permite contestar mi pregunta es para el
señor antón
su reflexión y dice no realmente siempre
hemos mejorado nuestros procedimientos
si el sistema no es perfecto como en
cualquier otra plataforma donde se
comparten vídeos como la que fue atacada
por la justicia hacia dos semanas
eso no fue lo que le pregunté señor
antón estoy preguntando si cree que
habría sido posible evitar tantas
víctimas si hubiesen hecho de esos
cambios antes
podemos y siempre queremos hacerlo mejor
los representantes de mandiá que
recalcan estar compitiendo con páginas
extranjeras que a menudo no están
reguladas y afirman colaborar con
instancias para luchar contra la
pornografía infantil en internet desde
hace algunos meses
demasiado poco y también demasiado tarde
según los diputados canadienses algunos
exigen la apertura de una investigación
penal en torno al grupo y sus 48
filiales hoy estamos aquí todos los
martes de 5 a 6 el movimiento recibe el
apoyo de varias redes de militantes en
américa del norte y en europa
rafael a días byers hace parte de una de
estas redes
lucha por obtener una mejor regulación
para el acceso a páginas de contenidos
para adultos no dejaremos que esto caiga
en el olvido aquí se habla mucho sobre
el comité de ética es algo importante
pero se puede olvidar rápido volveremos
todas las semanas para repetir no lo
olviden no olviden lo que está pasando
rafaela días byers hace parte de una de
estas redes lucha por obtener una mejor
regulación para el acceso a páginas de
contenido para adultos
yo milito desde 2017 para que internet
tenga los mismos controles que existen
en el mundo físico es decir que no se
permite que los jóvenes entren a bares
con bailarinas desnudas como aquí y
quebec esos mismos tipos de control
deberían existir en internet no queremos
impedir que la industria exista
globalmente pero debe respetar ciertas
reglas verificar y documentar que las
personas tienen más de son mayores que
que no sean niños y que sea de manera
consensuada
la petición para aumentar las
regulaciones para estas plataformas cada
vez están más presentes al otro lado del
atlántico
particularmente en francia un link
lecciones sobre meses
ante el aumento exponencial de
contenidos con abuso a menores y
explotación sexual en internet canadá
acaba de poner en marcha una consulta
nacional por iniciativa de la ciudadanía
digital una toma de conciencia tardía
animada desde hace años por los
profesionales de la industria del porno
tenemos todo quieres hacerlo con fuerza
nos volvemos a encontrar con debbie
nuestra actriz porno en quebec
[Música]
más tranquila después de ver que por
retiro dos tercios de los vídeos
sospechosos en su plataforma de vía
admite que esas páginas de contenido
sexual gratuito se han vuelto
ineludibles
digamos que yo comparto por redes
sociales snap chat o facebook que voy a
una grabación o algo por el estilo
relacionado con porno lo primero que me
preguntan es me puedes dar tu link
gratuito de pornhub donde puedo ver tus
vídeos gratis tienes muchos vídeos en
fort hood es lo primero que me preguntan
para de bill la profesión sigue siendo
un reto después de muchas dudas decidió
conciliar su vida de madre joven con una
carrera como actriz y puesto que será
necesario en unos años le explicará a
sus hijos la herencia que ha dejado en
internet basta que pongas mi nombre en
google y salen tres páginas donde
aparezco desnuda
un día tendrá que pasar lo sabrán yo
solo espero que mis hijos no lo vean
si un día decido que no quiero que haya
nada mío en internet ni fotos ni vídeos
que no exista huellas de que hice eso
creo que me costará más o menos medio
millón es extremadamente caro
la inmortalidad digital de los datos
personales es uno de los mayores retos
para la regulación del internet en el
siglo 21 las víctimas de pont hab han
pagado el precio durante mucho tiempo y
sus propietarios también por primera vez
en 13 años
[Música]
hasta aquí el programa reporteros de la
semana recuerde que para sintonizar esta
y las emisiones anteriores puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta la próxima
[Música]